we're different version here still takes
us almost two months
oh you're brand new and we brought you
out to that way
so Kenan his rehab program cow Oh
Weingarten yeah Street but put your own
crate okay I want you to do that only
now for about 18 19 years old
oh where did you start I just read lips
when I got a hit a lot of fields I was
six and a half years came you were clean
just six and a half years to wait for
you to do about the people people places
and things like
[Music]
tell me what your charlie you grew up
with one parent both parents I wrote
with my mother she was all black and
work for me working woman yeah she made
sure we got our education graduating it
was a house fire
brothers and sisters right between
Broadway and a 47-yard brother it was
good I had a good Navy until my mother
pays 2008 - that's all the phrase mm
it's a how old are you 22
and where'd you go from there being out
of prison jumping state to state
[Music]
prostitution manifest I would daily with
me
well I was like their horns throwing and
blowing and this trick thought he was
gonna just take something take my my
every mouth my body and I wasn't having
it
so I shot him in his Nick
and I shot in the back when he but he
survived because of three
how many years noble self defense since
they had it on camera huh so you do
anything no I just I just stayed in
County for almost two years of fighting
in case they do children of your own I'm
39 with nature okay no kids and what do
you see for your life from here what do
you want to do I want to get off the
streets I'm gonna go back home just
talking Dini back together once before
perfectly family at all
how did you first get introduced to
crack I used to see my anus mobile why
you see money my English by eight and
I'm in my twenties to my understand me
my twin brother fixing crack pipe so we
already know how to fix a little she's
here and I got curious one day I was
sixteen seventeen you know let me break
you know I got curious one day and I
wanted to see what they correct do to
make my a me describe my whole granny
house like RAM RAM searching to see what
make her take everything out of wound by
wrong wondering the time to search for
money and stuff I want to see what make
her do out it why the cracked make a
duty a nice and long so you seen all
kinds of crazy stuff
and Randolph Street butt-naked I've seen
people with prostitutes and tricks been
on a freeway didn't carry heavy six hour
thing lot of stuff
how much money do you make typically
every night 5/5 for something four
hundred four hundred seven dollars how
many guys is that this six
and that pays for your crack habit
in my room clothing their food in
Hodgins
safe back there